who is I kiddo training for I personally
believe the IPO trainings for absolutely
everyone when I say everyone I mean
everyone everyone from a 20 year old
who's interested in becoming Batman all
the way up to an 80 year old who's just
looking to get a little more out of life
and and preserve their health as best
they possibly can we do that by offering
a large variety of classes we have very
simple movement based classes that are
not going to put your body in any kind
of danger but will allow you to maintain
as much physical and mental abilities
you possibly can will probably increase
your strength and flexibility and give
you something fun to do we scaled it
also all the way up on the other side
too we have very vigorous intense
sparring practices where we do weapons
sparring unarmed sparring we do lots of
multiple attackers situations extreme
situations that are their vigorous hard
practice so if you're interested in that
kind of practice that's available to you
hear that I clear president we have all
walks of life training we have
professionals newspaper writers
investment brokers attorneys training
here we also have stay-at-home moms and
students and retirees so any kind of
Walker like you can imagine their
training here at IQ go Fresno we have
ages from for all the way up to 70 and I
believe everyone's getting a lot out of
their IPO training I kiddo is something
that you can do that's interesting and
it gives you a challenge and every day
you want to come in to the dojo see what
new things happening for you and and to
watch yourself progress and change so
when I say everyone can train an idea I
really mean that especially here like
your Fresno our goal is to make training
interesting for everyone right so no one
feels left behind and no one feels like
they're being stagnated and they can't
be challenged so I can arrange for
everyone if you're interested doing this
kind of training you should come in and
try it class i'm chris hein head
instructor my Kido president
you